model success
the fastest way to accomplish any goal
any challenge you have for yourself
is to model success find people who've
already done what you're trying to do
and put their strategies to work for you
otherwise if you try to think of every
new idea yourself come up with every
answer yourself
you're going to keep beating your head
against brick walls and not seeing the
results that you deserve
for your business i got a great question
from one of my youtube viewers
noreen who's trying to start a cosmetic
climb and wanted my advice on how to
start a cosmetic line
so i haven't started cosmetic line
before but if i was going into that
business what i would do is try to model
success
i would look at who has started some of
the most successful
cosmetic lines in the business and how
do they do it
not how did they make an extra million
dollars now but how did they start how
did they go from
i have an idea for a product and get it
in the department stores
i look at people at coco chanel how did
coco chanel get started and what lessons
can you learn from her success
i know one of her strategies in the
early days was she would go to
department stores
and hand out samples of her perfume and
when the buyer
came and said what are you doing and
when she saw that everybody seemed to be
really liking her perfume
that helped make a deal possible for
coco chanel where otherwise she couldn't
get the chance
to open the door but that's one example
look at all of these successful cosmetic
lines
and see how they got started what were
the factors that led to their success
how did they get their first
customer and model them i remember when
i had my first company
i really struggled at the beginning i
was making 300 bucks a month
not enough to survive i almost gave up
repeatedly
and uh was willing to try anything i
felt like i tried everything
and and nothing was working out i had a
great product and i couldn't understand
why this was so hard because the books i
read and the websites i visited
and the shows i watched everything
seemed to be so easy like follow these
eight steps and you'll be successful
well i followed those eight steps a
million times
and i wasn't successful and one of the
big breakthroughs for me
came when i realized that i wasn't the
first guy to try to do this before
my first company was a software company
and i had no background in software
before
apart from using you know a computer but
i wasn't a software designer
and the breakthrough moment came when i
did realize that i'm not the first guy
to try to sell software before and i
went and i modeled
some of the largest and most successful
software companies in the world and one
in particular was microsoft
and again i don't care how bill gates
makes money now but how did he go
from nothing from that idea to getting
his first customer what did he do what
did he say what were his actions what
was what was his mindset
who did he need to connect with and i
took those strategies and applied them
to my business
and i finally started to see results
for him was through partnerships so he
made partnerships he had software he
partnered with hardware companies
his big deal came with ibm was a seven
million dollar deal that first one with
ibm
that really put the company on the map
but before that he still made
partnerships with other
hardware companies and they sold their
their products as a bundle
and so i applied that strategy and
within the first month
i closed my first partnership deal and i
made 13 and a half thousand dollars
now that may not seem like a lot of
money to you 13k but to me i'm making
300 bucks a month this was
this was like eureka oh my god i struck
it rich this is amazing
somebody actually believes in what i'm
doing i'm seeing some positive momentum
finally after all this failure and
struggling
and i just kept copying that again and i
applied it again and again and again and
closed more partnerships and more
partnerships and continued to grow my
business and eventually
uh got acquired by someone who was a
potential partner they loved us so much
that they wanted to buy my business
and i wish i had discovered it earlier i
wish i discovered the strategy so much
earlier
because i almost shut down like i almost
quit my business and thought maybe i
should
listen to my friends and go back and get
a job
and i'm so grateful that i didn't but i
came close many times to having to do
that
and so if you're struggling with your
business right now if you don't have a
lot of experience
in in the field and it's a first time
thing for you you can't get this thing
off the ground
model success find someone who has done
it who's had success
in your field look at the cosmetic lines
company see how they did it
learn from their mistakes so you don't
have to make all the mistakes yourself
and you crunch down your learning curve
so instead of it taking you years and
years and years to achieve success you
can do it a lot
faster because you're modeling things
that work so i've never had success in
the cosmetic
field but i could have it and to do it i
just modeled the people who've had a lot
of success doing it
apply their strategies and make it work
for me and it can work for you too
believe for those of you watching you
like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
always makes me want to do more for you
and
i love seeing your comments come in they
really make a difference for me
and give me a strong impact every time i
read them in the morning
so please leave a comment below if you
have a question leave it underneath i'll
make a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon